i have um
a private community a lot of guys come
in it and um you know they want to do
some work on themselves
and this is a recurring thing that i've
seen come up
a few times in the last week
and let's be honest i mean guys think
this way a lot so most guys
they'll come to this space they'll read
some books they'll watch a bunch of
videos they'll tune into some podcasts
some provide some information some
some try to hold
horrible people accountable
um i'm going to use one spoke here as a
visual
kind of explain this to you just going
to color it in here
because this is what most guys do
the vast majority of people that come
across
this information red pill information
they you know they unplug
they see the code in the matrix they see
what's going on
this is what they end up doing here's
your visual folks
so you see the
the spokes in the wheel and by the way
like these things here i'm gonna try to
get my face at it so it's not trying to
focus on my face so these things here
could be
10 12 17 spokes depending on how i
wanted to find it but i want to narrow
it down to these top seven
and most people will come in they'll get
red pill aware so this one spoke here
that's colored in right up to the tip
okay all the way in not just the tip but
all the way up
that one there would be
rpa just call it red pill
awareness
a lot of guys can get there very very
easily
they'll read a few books they got my
book they've watched a few of my videos
they've seen a few the podcast episodes
you know they follow me on social and
they consume some other content like
okay i got it i see the code in the
matrix looks money game status
right and then they're like okay okay
okay so now they're aware
and then they just kind of stop there
which is so bizarre to me
or they'll start complaining or sulking
or they'll go to a dark place or they'll
go looking for
others to uh you know confirm the
reasons why they're not getting what
they want and then these other ones
let's put
um
what did i jot down here in my
description notes here looks money
status game frame and captivation
captivation is really important i'm
going to talk about that one because a
lot of dudes miss that especially the
older guys with bank too
looks money status
game
frame
captivation and rpa
okay
so they got one
that one right there they got the one
but then guess what
they don't bother with the other ones
they just don't
they'll just they'll just go you know
what my looks department is eh
what am i going to do about it my money
status is eh i'm just going to keep
working my minimum wage job or whatever
you know annual pay gets you it's like
and like
if you can go 10 out of 10 on your
awareness level see the code in the
matrix unplug from the comforting lies
see the uncomfortable truth
understand what women respond to you see
it all you're fully red pill aware but
then you're like eh
you know what there's only so much money
out there
and that guy has a lot of it and that
guy has a lot of it how the hell am i
supposed to get out it gets some of it
there's it's just impossible for me to
get it and then they're like you know
like a four out of ten in the money and
then that means that they don't have a
lot of status they don't have a lot of
influence so they're like a three out of
ten or a four out of ten or a five out
of ten maybe they're better looking or
they're you know a reasonable athlete on
a sports team with a following of 500
people or something like that you see
what i'm saying like these things will
start to fluctuate
so they're so they're fully aware but
they just kind of don't bother with the
other things game you know
they don't bother trying to game they
don't try to bother they don't bother
trying to game women when they go on
dates they don't bother trying to game
you know people in their lives when
they're when they're going about things
right like to to see how they respond to
certain things right
frame's another really important one
some guys will get full-on red red
pillow where the trout cons love to do
this so they'll go full on you know red
pill awareness they'll get a girl they
start dating you know she lets them uh
you know touch her boobies uh she
touches his pp they start to date things
start to go well they become exclusive
and they start you know like their
boyfriend and girlfriend or something
like that but then they totally lose a
frame in their relationship even though
what brought them to the space got them
the information
they see the code in the matrix they
unplug and they just like you know what
i'm just going to leave it i'm not i'm
not going to apply that
right it's like
taking years and years of boxing or
jujitsu or karate or something like that
and then some guy picks a fight with you
and you just stand there and you do
nothing with it
same thing
let's move on
let's talk about the captivation one
it's another
big big spoke in the wheel actually you
know what this is a huge spoken wheel a
lot of guys a lot of guys really really
miss this one too
big time big time you know who misses
captivation the most and all it really
means is
well here let's google the the
dictionary definition terms we can break
it down exactly
oh what does the webster say
the state of being intensely interested
as by awe or terror that be even even
better you know
you don't you don't want somebody to be
terrified of you but you want them to
not be particularly comfortable right
now the state of being intensely
interested
in something
captivated by is very very important i
see a lot of more seasoned men out there
i've got i've got one friend of mine he
um
he's in my group he uh recently had a uh
a nice date with a younger lady didn't
go so well he had a slight mishap with
his uh mode of transportation
um i know you're watching my friends
that's why i'm i'm mentioning you and i
said to him early on when we were
chatting because he was really
struggling you know he had his like he
really had his game together he had his
money sword he's a good looking guy
takes care of himself like pro like
properly executed with self-care you
know for his age you wouldn't you
wouldn't think that he's 60 like he
looks at least 10 to 15 years younger
and again you know had number of exits
in his business has done very very well
but he didn't really have anything
interesting going on again the
definition of captivation a state of
being intensely interested
women like you can do anything to women
they've said this for a long time you
can do anything to women except bore
them
you can't bore them you can do pretty
much anything else literally but you
can't bore them women don't have
patience for boring
right
so you're a rich guy
decent looking you're in good shape
but you don't have anything interesting
to do with women when you take them out
why
you know it's like all these spokes on
the wheel you could you could have the
looks the money the status red pill
awareness bubble but you're not
captivating
that wheel's not gonna you put pressure
on it
and then it transfers into the hub as
you're rolling down
the spokes of the wheel that aren't
fully maximized out are not going to
hold the weight of the wheel it's going
to run lopsided it's not going to work
properly and that's what most guys get
themselves into if you see what i'm
saying again look at that visual just
look at it
that's what most guys do
oh i'm fully red pill aware i know what
i know women respond to blah blah blah
but they're fat or they're broke or
they're not interesting they don't have
any hobbies
i had a conversation
the other week with another guy
um
he kind of went into a dark place you
know like a sulking area of the internet
and
collaborated with a few other guys in
that space
who confirmed his you know his deepest
darkest fears
and um
he started to walk away from that which
is a you know which is a good move
but when i asked him like what he likes
to do for fun
you know like what do you what do you do
when you're not working because
basically what he does he works and then
he goes home and he works and he goes
home he's like okay well what do you do
for fun right because you know because
he's trying to date women i get it fine
you know that's your imperative you're
on this earth to scatter seed you like
women i get it fine
but there's work to do so it says to him
what do you do for fun
i like to go to the gym
i like to work i like to talk to some of
the guys in the i.t department
and you know stuff like that
okay but
if you ask a chick out what are you
gonna tell her like let's go and go to
the gym together because he's not
particularly fit like he's not a chad
okay he's not a jacked muscled up
shoulders like boulders big dude right
so it's not like you know he's going to
say hey let's go to these he's he's kind
of he's kind of moving in that direction
he's starting to anyway but on a scale
of like rip chad to poindexter he's more
on the poindexter side still and that's
not a disparaging comment that's just
stating fact
and it's like okay if you're on that
side of the scale you're not going to
get an attractive woman to want to go
out and do something like work out with
poindexter she'll probably work out with
chat
so it's like what are you gonna do to be
captivating like what do you do that's
interesting when you're not working and
you know guys if you're in your 20s
why don't you have something going on
like i understand older guys like older
guys have social networks they might
have business forums that they're
involved in entrepreneurs groups
they might have obligations to you know
their own children if they're fathers
so they might have less time but if
you're a younger guy and you're dating
and you don't have anything interesting
going on in your world how are you going
to introduce women into it you know
you don't go to her world okay when
you're dating women guys this is
especially true for older guys older
guys make this mistake a lot a lot of
the times too you don't you don't go
into her world and be like oh let's go
to the justin bieber concert or you know
whatever that narrative is you get the
point you're not going into her world
you're inviting her into your world
and a woman is only going to want to
come into your world and do something
with you
if you're interesting if you're
captivating if you can keep our
attention and it doesn't take a lot of
money
i'll be honest with you guys it doesn't
matter where you live
this guy happened to live in a uh nice
part of the world i'm not going to say
we're very nice part of the world that
happens to have
waterfalls and nice national parks and
i'm like you know like what do you do
for fun
oh you know i um
basically nothing you know what i got
well
why don't you invite her out on a date
pick up a couple of uh you know cold
drinks or coffees or something or tell
her to make a picnic for example you
know if this is a longer one if it's a
second date or something like that
and then take her to go and explore
let's go into this national park and go
and hike over to this waterfall
right
that's interesting that'll be
captivating a lot of women are down for
stuff like that but if you're just like
ah you know i just go to work and i like
to go to the gym and i sometimes talk to
my friends after work and we have a beer
sort of thing that's not particularly
interesting great you're red pillow
where
what about the other spokes of the wheel
you